en can academy ya hemos hecho varios
vídeos explicando cómo funciona la
evolución y la selección natural pero se
me ocurrió hacer un vídeo dedicado
específicamente a profundizar en la
evidencia que tenemos de la evolución y
la selección natural y voy a empezar con
esta cita que tenemos aquí nada tiene
sentido en biología si no es a la luz de
la evolución por co2 2 samskip que fue
un biólogo muy importante y muy famoso
que ya se murió y bueno es precisamente
por esto por lo que es importante que
veamos toda la evidencia que tenemos de
la evolución y de la selección natural
porque además antes de la teoría de la
evolución la biología era solamente un
conjunto de observaciones y
clasificaciones sin que tuviera una
narrativa coherente acerca de cómo éstas
se produjeron y desde que darwin expuso
esta teoría a mitades del siglo 19 hemos
tenido muchas más herramientas y mucha
más evidente
para respaldar a esta teoría además de
todas las observaciones que tenían hasta
ese punto ahora tenemos muchas
herramientas para hacer datación y
tenemos los registros fósiles que
proporcionan mucha más evidencia y
además también tenemos nuestras
herramientas de microbiología y de
genética que proporcionan evidencia
todavía más sólida y bueno yo sé que por
ahí hay muchas personas que están
diciendo o la teoría de la evolución es
simplemente una teoría pero tan sólida
como una teoría puede llegar a ser y
como lo dijo todos los suns que la
biología como la conocemos y todo el
progreso que hemos hecho
honestamente no tendría ningún sentido
sin la teoría de la evolución y
probablemente no habría sucedido pero
ahora voy a explicar de una forma muy
burda tres tipos de evidencia que
tenemos acerca de la evolución y de la
selección natural el primer tipo de
evidencia es estructural
y este es el tipo de cosas que
personajes como darwin estuvieron
observando las evidencias estructurales
tienen sentido a la luz de la evolución
y la selección natural y aquí estamos
hablando acerca de las macro estructuras
cosas que podemos observar con nuestros
ojos o con un microscopio muy simple el
siguiente nivel es lo que hemos
aprendido a lo largo de los últimos 100
años a nivel microscópico es a nivel
micro la microbiología y especialmente
en genética esto realmente ha afirmado
la teoría de la evolución y ahora el
último nivel que vamos a mencionar es la
observación directa observación directa
y aquí es donde realmente se van más
allá de una teoría estamos observando
como sucede y muchas veces muchas
personas dicen algo así bueno es
simplemente una teoría sabes esa teoría
dice que sucedió a lo largo de miles de
millones de años pero
nadie realmente estaba ahí para
observarlo y verificarlo así es que
aunque haya un montón de evidencia nadie
puede saber que realmente sucedió sin
embargo si lo estás observando
directamente tú sabes que en verdad está
sucediendo y cómo vamos a ver en este
vídeo la evolución no sólo ocurre a lo
largo de millones o decenas de millones
de años la evolución sucede y la podemos
observar mientras sucede todo el tiempo
a una escala en el tiempo que el ser
humano puede observar puede ser
simplemente una cuestión de meses o años
entonces vamos a ver cada una de estas
vamos a empezar con evidencias
estructurales y lo estamos viendo de una
forma muy burdas yo te recomiendo que
hagas un poco más de investigación por
tu parte si te interesa este tema y vas
a ver que hay muchísimas muchísimas
fuentes de este tipo de evidencia pero
bueno lo primero de lo que quiero hablar
es de las estructuras homólogas
estructuras homólogas y la palabra
homólogas se refiere a cosas que tienen
una estructura similar o posición
similar tienen ancestría similar pero no
necesariamente tienen las mismas
funciones por aquí tenemos el antebrazo
humano y la muñeca y aquí tenemos
estructuras homólogas en perros aves y
ballenas sin embargo esta parte de estos
animales tienen funciones completamente
diferentes los humanos casi nunca
caminan sobre sus manos los perros si
caminan sobre sus patas delanteras y las
aves no caminan utilizan estas
estructuras para mover sus alas y aquí
la ballena pues ésta forma parte de las
aletas aunque aquí tiene unas aletas
estaba llena y los utiliza para impulsar
o controlar su movimiento en el agua
incluso aunque en todos estos animales
estos huesos tengan funciones
completamente distintas y al principio
por afuera en un humano un perro un ave
y una ballena se ven completamente
diferentes sin embargo cuando lo vemos
más profundamente cuando vemos la
estructura de estos huesos podemos ver
una similitud inquietante sobre todo si
lo ponemos estos códigos de color de
esta forma así es que esta es una pista
muy fuerte de que los humanos perros
aves y ballenas comparten un ancestro
común un poco menos alejado en el tiempo
en comparación con algunos otros
organismos que no tienen las estructuras
homólogas mencionadas en este ejemplo y
otra cosa curiosa es que si tratáramos
de construir estructuras que realizarán
las funciones de cada una de estas no
sería lo más evidente o no sería lo
esperado que estas estructuras tuvieran
tal homología entre sí
todas estas especies existen el día de
hoy en el planeta sin embargo también
encontramos estructuras homólogas en
registros fósiles en los últimos 100
años particularmente a principios del
siglo pasado nos volvimos muy buenos
observando los estratos de las rocas y
poniéndoles fecha haciendo la adaptación
de estos estados nos volvimos excelentes
diciendo esta capa se asentó hace x
millones de años y esta otra capa se
asentó un poco más recientemente y esta
se asentó hace mucho menos tiempo y esta
es más reciente y también nos volvimos
muy buenos observando fósiles en estas
capas y diciendo ok hace 20 millones de
años había seres vivos que se veían más
o menos así
luego hace 10 millones de años había
estas otras especies que se veían más o
menos así y un ejemplo clásico es si
observamos unos organismos que se
parecen mucho a los caballos
estamos hablando de caballos cebras
asnos y mulas ese tipo de especies de
animales la estructura ósea de las
especies recientes es esta pero si nos
alejamos en el tiempo entre 12 y 5
millones de años
tenemos fósiles que se ven así y son
bastante parecidos así es que no es
difícil imaginarse que estos organismos
evolucionaron en estos otros pero luego
nos alejamos un poco más en el tiempo de
16 a 12 millones de años y tenemos estos
otros fósiles que se parecen mucho a los
anteriores
que también podemos imaginarnos que
evolucionan en estos así es que es un
proceso gradual y vuelve a suceder otra
vez con estos que son de hace más de 34
millones de años así es que podemos ver
cómo sucede de una forma muy gradual y
también podemos estudiar el mecanismo a
través del cual sucede esto tenemos
varios vídeos en khan academy al
respecto tenemos variaciones en las
especies
tenemos el ambiente que está
seleccionando a los más aptos pero el
medio ambiente puede cambiar o pueden
suceder catástrofes y por ello existen
distintas formas de selección natural
distintas combinaciones pueden surgir
que son más convenientes para el medio
ambiente en el que habita el organismo y
tener algunas características que los
hagan estar más adaptados al medio
ambiente y entonces se empiezan a
reproducir más aumentan su tasa de
supervivencia y se convierten en la
especie dominante se apoderan de ciertas
partes de un nicho o un ecosistema
11 sucede ese cambio heredable en los
rasgos es un cambio que se hereda a lo
largo del tiempo y cuando vemos el
registro fósil tiene mucho sentido decir
ok esta es evidencia muy fuerte acerca
de la evolución y nos dice que los
animales que vemos hoy en día no fueron
puestos así tal cual como están no
fueron creados de repente y no han
cambiado desde entonces sino que se
encuentran bajo un cambio constante que
podemos observar en el registro fósil
bueno y ahora vamos al siguiente tipo de
evidencia que tenemos acerca de la
evolución pero voy a poner una pequeña
advertencia aquí porque la persona que
creó esto su nombre era aquel y era una
persona muy controversial algunas de sus
teorías eran completamente falsas y
bueno este diagrama que tenemos aquí lo
dibujo modificando un poco las figuras
para tener un argumento más fuerte sin
embargo estos
y están bastante cerca de ser los
correctos y es bastante convincente nos
muestra el desarrollo embrionario de
distintas especies desde el pescado aquí
en la izquierda pasando por reptiles y
por aves y mamíferos no humanos hasta
llegar a los humanos y podemos observar
en las primeras etapas del desarrollo
embrionario como son inquietantemente
parecidos y de hecho en esta etapa de
los embriones todos éstos todos estos
tienen primordios de hendiduras
branquiales que conforme el embrión se
va desarrollando se va diferenciando en
estructuras más adecuadas para cada uno
de estos animales y ya que él es el que
nos dijo que la ontogenia recapitula la
filogenia que es simplemente una forma
muy elegante de decir que el desarrollo
embrionario nos cuenta la historia del
camino evolutivo lo cual no es cierto
pero todavía se puede escuchar a algunas
personas citando
sin embargo sus dibujos y todas estas
observaciones es evidencia bastante
convincente de que estos seres vivos
comparten algún ancestro común y tienen
un origen similar aunque estas especies
poco a poco se fueron diferenciando cada
vez más a lo largo del tiempo a través
del proceso de selección natural pero
bueno todo esto que hemos visto hasta
este momento se mantiene a un nivel
estructural macro ahora vamos a pasar a
la parte de microbiología son cosas que
podemos observar directamente ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es hablar acerca de
microestructuras de microbiología micro
biología y entre más entendemos la
microbiología más convincente es la
teoría de la evolución porque por
ejemplo si nos ponemos a observar todos
los seres vivos que conocemos todos
contienen adn todos se involucran al adn
y la forma en la que el adn se replica y
se traduce y se transcribe es muy
similar para todas las formas de vida y
todo esto de que el adn codifica
proteínas y que las proteínas están
formadas por aminoácidos es algo que
vemos siempre en todos los seres vivos
lo cual nuevamente es una pista muy
importante de que todos los seres vivos
provienen de un ancestro común y además
todas estas proteínas son realmente muy
similares mucho más similares de lo que
son las estructuras homólogas además
todos estos seres vivos no sólo
comparten todos estos procesos y
estructuras la información almacenada en
el adn es una evidencia muy fuerte
almacenan la misma información lo cual
es evidencia muy fuerte de la evolución
esta es una imagen que conseguía en la
página 23 antes
pero esto y vas a encontrar un montón de
datos como estos esto nos dice que tanta
semejanza genética tenemos con las
plantas levaduras moscas de la fruta
ratones chimpancés y el hecho de que
compartamos el 26 por ciento de los
genes con la levadura es impresionante
en un nivel macroscópico no nos
parecemos nada a la levadura pero si nos
vamos a un nivel microbiológico tenemos
bastante en común con la levadura y
ahora con los chimpancés pues si nos
parecemos bastante tenemos facciones
comúnes gestos comunes incluso
comportamientos en común y muchas veces
los chimpancés nos pueden parecer
inquietantemente parecidos a nosotros
pero a nivel genético podemos comprobar
lo mucho que realmente somos parecidos y
bueno esta similitud genética nos enseña
como los ratones y bueno incluso las
moscas de la fruta
son mucho más cercanos a nosotros que
las plantas o las bacterias si nos
fijamos en el árbol de la vida entero si
nos fijamos en la evidencia genética
seres vivos como los ratones e incluso
las moscas de la fruta son bastante
cercanos a los seres humanos sobre todo
si los comparamos con plantas o con
microbios pero nuevamente nosotros los
humanos compartimos con todos los seres
vivos el adn y las proteínas y los
aminoácidos y todos los procesos pero el
hecho de que utilizando el adn ahora
podemos medir qué tan lejanos son a
nosotros nos permite crear un árbol de
la vida bastante preciso sobre todo nos
permite pensar que tan lejos en el
pasado teníamos un ancestro común del
cual evolucionamos
de lo último que prometí que íbamos a
hablar es acerca de la evidencia directa
ahora vamos a ver evidencia directa de
la evolución y bueno de hecho hablo un
poco de esto en el primer vídeo acerca
de la evolución esto de la evidencia
directa la estamos viendo todo el tiempo
con las bacterias por ejemplo cuando
tenemos bacterias y tomamos antibióticos
para eliminar a esas bacterias por
cierto los médicos siempre recomiendan
no abusar de los antibióticos justo por
esta razón porque entre más utilicemos
antibióticos más provocamos esta
selección natural fuerte que beneficia a
las bacterias que son resistentes al
antibiótico así es que si sigues
utilizando mucho antibiótico y las
bacterias siguen cambiando hay cada vez
más y más variación
bueno pues vas a matar a un montón de
bacterias pero si tan siquiera una de
esas bacterias resulta ser resistente al
antibiótico
estamos favoreciendo a esa bacteria
porque estamos matando a toda la
competencia y entonces está súper
bacteria y así le llamamos a las
bacterias que son resistentes a los
antibióticos está súper bacteria tiene
todo el campo libre para reproducirse
todo lo que quiera y no tiene
competencia y los antibióticos no van a
poder hacer nada para controlarla y si
te fijas en la medicina hoy en día esto
se convierte en una carrera porque los
médicos tienen que desarrollar nuevos
antibióticos porque las bacterias se
vuelven cada vez más resistentes a los
antibióticos existentes y esto es
evolución y selección natural sucediendo
frente a nosotros a una escala que el
ser humano definitivamente puede
observar y otro ejemplo como este es el
virus de la gripe que cada año te tienes
que poner una nueva vacuna porque los
virus siguen cambiando y entonces tu
sistema inmunológico pierde la habilidad
para reconocerlos
porque cambian tanto